[Music]
it's taking some work but I finally have
them the worst of the
[Music]
worst where let's just say I put him in
a hole and thre away the
hole there's rumors Amando that some of
them have a abilities oh yeah I have
seen things maybe Superman was some kind
of Beacon for them to creep back from
the
Shadows I want to assemble a task force
of the most dangerous people on the
planet who I think can do some
good they're bad guys exactly and if
anything goes wrong we blame them we
have built in
deniability what makes you think you can
control them because getting people to
act against their own self-interest is
what I do for a
living
I started a
Jo which started the whole world
[Music]
crying are you the devil but I didn't
see
all you need to know is you work for
me
[Music]
the so that's it huh where the
PSIs we some kind of Suicide
Squad let go save the
[Music]
world
you're in so much
trouble hope you got him
serious now this tell about the crazy
ones
huh oh I'm not going to kill you that
the was on
[Music]
me I'm just going to hurt you really
really
bad